voilà
les petits chats
sur la bonne voie
c'est moi
bon
j'y crois pas qu aux efforts
voilà qu'un toit
hier l'eau
mais là est mort
merde
enfin son
combat face à faire de la merde
bon
allez je n'ai plus
à cette près de toulouse
il ya quelques jours des déboires ont
sauvé plusieurs chatons lors de leurs
tournées quotidiennes je suis docteur de
la vidéo de sauvetage des petits chats
donc le chauffeur moi j'ai dit à maman
bravo à dimitri et morgane de tori peur
du l'oreille fine entre 1,7 et chatons
très peu qui passent dans la benne
comment ça s'est passé mais maudit
sagnol donc on a bloqué le camion
le jeune entre dans la trémie arômes et
tous ces sacs vous avez vu cet été dans
un gros sac notre vie du mal à les
repérer parce que j'attends mieux de
pâques aux états membres ce n'est pas la
première fois que christian on fait ce
genre de sauvetage il ya un an et demi
un infirme découverte pareil quoi ce que
les collègues et moi j'en avais deux
dans une porsche a fermé
un minois ten qui tout cas d'un jour
racheté en colère donc bien j'ai filmé
les yeux et j'ai partagé sur facebook et
tik tok et il voit la paix en fait du
coup avait
jamais demandé des nouvelles donc je
continue à faire des vidéos je mets des
trois jours donc je l'appelle essoufflé
et eux
c'est sa star sa finale miss tic toc
c'est un clown au laminoir aucune au
bonheur c'est aussi sur tik tok que
christian a donné des nouvelles des
biches accusations
voilà bien une fois de plus c'est une
monnaie rigueur on est intrigué
voilà
les a sortis du sac il y'en avait deux
qui était mal en point et l'esprit très
peu
ces deux les a perdus
heureusement pour les trois autres j'ai
trouvé une famille de sauver saab la
saison ouvert les yeux c'est génial les
ovules avait mis à part le 3e séparés la
moins senti investi clarté de calais
[Musique]